- [Instructor] In this video,
we're going to get a little bit
of practice setting up
systems of linear equations
based on a word problem.
We're not actually going
to end up solving it.
You can do that if you
like just for kicks.
But really we're going to
just focus on setting it up.
So here we're told Lauren uses
a blend of dark roast beans
and light roast beans to
make coffee at her cafe.
She needs 80 kilograms of beans
in total for her next order.
Dark roast beans cost $3 per kilogram,
light roast beans cost $2 per kilogram,
and someone wants to spend $220 total.
Let D be the number of kilograms
of dark roast beans she buys
and L be the number of kilograms
of light roast beans she buys.
All right, so based on this information
that we've been given, see
if you can pause this video
and set up a system of equations.
And it's going to have two equations
with two unknowns, D and L,
that in theory we could solve
to figure out the right
number of kilograms
of dark roast beans and light roast beans
that Karen should use.
So pause this video and
try to work that out.
All right, now let's do it together.
And what I'm going to do
is I'm going to underline.
So let's see, we know
that D is dark roast beans
and the L is the number of
kilograms of light roast beans.
And then they tell us here,
they say she needs 80
kilograms of beans in total.
So what we could say is,
hey, the number of kilograms
of dark roast beans plus
the number of kilograms
of light roast beans needs
to be equal to 80 kilograms.
So the number of kilograms
of dark roast beans
plus the number of kilograms
of light roast beans.
(laughs) I'm having trouble
saying light roast beans.
Well, this, what I just underlined here,
it says needs to be 80 kilograms in total.
So that needs to be 80.
So this number of kilograms
plus this number of kilograms
is going to be equal
to your total number of kilograms.
All right, so I have one
equation with two unknowns.
Let's see if we can get another one.
So next, they say dark roast
beans cost $3 per kilogram,
light roast beans cost $2 per kilogram,
and she wants to spend $220 total.
So what I just underlined
in this aquamarine color
we can set up another equation with.
And if you haven't already set
up your system of equations,
see if you can now do that.
See if you can set up
this second equation.
Pause the video.
All right, well, the way to think
about it is we just have
to have an expression
for how much did she
spend on dark roast beans,
how much did she spend
on light roast beans,
and then we need to
add those two together,
and that needs to be equal to $220
'cause that's how much she
wants to spend in total.
So how much does she
spend on dark roast beans?
Well, it's going to be
the number of kilograms
of dark roast beans that she buys,
and it says that it cost $3 per kilogram,
so we're gonna multiply it by three.
$3 per kilogram times
the number of kilograms
of dark roast beans.
This is how much she
spends on dark roast beans.
And so how much is she going
to spend on light roast beans?
Well, she buys L kilograms
of light roast beans.
They told us that there.
And they cost $2 per kilogram,
so $2 per kilogram times
the number of kilograms.
This is how much she spends
on light roast beans.
So you add how much she
spends on dark roast
to how much she spends on light roast,
and so this is going to be $220 in total.
And there you have it.
We have our two equations
with two unknowns,
and so now we could go and solve it,
but you can do that outside of this video.
But the whole point of
this video is to understand
how to construct these
based on the constraints,
based on the information
that we see in this.
So typically when you're
trying to set these up,
there's often a sentence or two
that will focus on one equation.
So this first one is
saying, hey, the kilograms,
let's add those up for the
total number of kilograms.
And then there's another
sentence or two that'll focus on,
in this case, some other equation.
In this case, it's the price.
So the price of the dark
plus the price of the light
is going to be equal to the
total amount she wants to spend.